so I'm a sociologist who graduated from
PhD at Oxford a couple of years ago and
I am interested in a variety of
different subjects brexit European Union
political attitudes psychometrics
personality evolution and I came to
prominence at least to a small extent
following a controversy after my
appointment at st. Edmund's College
Cambridge which occurred in the autumn
of 2018 basically some students and
academics made a series of complaints to
the college about me these complaints
were not trivial they alleged that I was
a racist pseudoscientist and they called
for a investigation into my appointment
at the college an investigation was
undertaken and five months later I was
dismissed from my role at the college
and made unemployed so here I am today
and I've decided to try to take some
kind of legal action against the college
I know the face hit so here I am today
like this is my rock bottom
well welcome we can't talk about the
details of the case for legal reasons
but just in broad brushstrokes I mean
some of the accusations that were made
of us that you're a pseudo-scientists
that you were doing a research into
these super controversial race and IQ
stuff and one of the interesting things
as well I wanted you to get you to touch
on is that the vast majority of the
people who file who supported the motion
to have you dismissed with scientists or
scholars in areas that have nothing to
do with what you actually research so
there are people like English literature
professors making assertions as to the
validity of your research so just give
us an overview of the whole situation
yeah so there was this open letter sent
to the newspapers in early December
which was initially signed by a couple
of hundred academics
and subsequently over the next few days
signed by 586 in total and the headline
of the open letter was no to race as
pseudoscience at Cambridge University
where I'd been employed and the charges
in the open letter were that I had been
involved in work that would be that
could be considered pseudo-scientific
and that I'd attended a certain
conference in London called the London
conference on intelligence and that my
work had been or was liable to be
misused by certain bad actors with the
purpose of harming vulnerable
populations around the world and as you
correctly pointed out the open letter
was signed by a large number of people
many of whom one would suspect probably
didn't have that much expertise in the
relevant areas actually a research
assistant and I went through the entire
list of signatories and identified the
subject for each one and we found that
only a relatively small number were in
subjects like biology or psychology I
think less than 10% in those disciplines
which could be considered relevant to
the subject matter at hand a great deal
were in subjects like gender studies and
critical race Theory confirmed
everybody's racist and qualitative
sociology history and English literature
as you said I'm hesitant to completely
dismiss someone's opinion just because
I'm not in the same field as me but in
this case it wouldn't be totally
unreasonable to presume many of them
just sort of surah surah notice for an
open letter about someone who's been
accused of racism and thought well I
better sign that because I'm against
racism and then you know days or weeks
later it all broke out in the press
[Music]